i invite you to join the discussion on
the david pakman show
reddit davidpakman.com r-e-d-d-i-t
more than 19 000 of you have already
done that a few
interesting posts i spotted one is
about the suicide rate that donald trump
has been talking about lately
asking why does no one ever question
trump on the high suicide rate
falling life expectancy and rising
opioid usage
before covid19 whenever he brings them
up as a reason to reopen the country
yeah this is a very fair question we are
being gasoline daily by donald trump
when donald trump pulls out a piece of
paper from his suit jacket
with a graph of the uh
just number of tests that the united
states has done
we are being gasoline right we are a
country of 331 million people and what
matters is the per capita testing rate
when donald trump now
says listen staying home can make people
depressed people could commit suicide
people are
addicted to drugs these are things
donald trump has not indicated he ever
cared about before and they were
problems before so
you're completely right to point out the
cynical nature of that and i wish donald
trump were asked about it but you know
he would just
lie and move on to the next question
another user says reminds us
that justice ruth bader ginsburg is in
the hospital with an infection
which is not good news and i
i want to just take this as an
opportunity to remind everybody
that we want justice ruth bader ginsburg
to recover and we wish her the best and
we want her to stay on the court
she says she wants to be on it until
she's 90 and we want her to be able to
do that and that's
absolutely fantastic and we love her and
it reminds us of the fact
that there is a level of dread that we
experience
when we hear that she's in the hospital
and we know
that donald trump is president and gets
to pick supreme court justices just a
reminder
about the importance of who is
allowed to select the next supreme court
justice very very
important lastly a post on our subreddit
from user john
x wall who says how can you prove you
are not
a sexual assaulter i don't know the
answer to this i think that this is
something that needs to be discussed
and uh you all know my positions on on
allegations of sexual assault
i believe that as a general rule um
these need to be taken seriously
uh they need to be investigated we need
to um
ensure that men or women who are victims
of sexual assault are not dissuaded from
coming forward
because of how they expect to be treated
or shame or whatever else
i don't know how you prove that you
didn't sexually assault someone
when there is not a criminal proceeding
i think that
many of us if there is actually a
criminal trial
about rape for example and the
individual is found not guilty
of course we all know you can be found
not guilty and have
actually done the thing you were accused
of but legally be not guilty
but i believe that there is more of a
sense that when you're found not guilty
of rape you didn't do it even though of
course that that's not always the case
when you have an allegation that never
gets to
a police report or a criminal proceeding
and
the accused perpetrator denies it
i don't know how you prove you didn't do
it i really don't
and um sir i don't even have anything to
add i would leave it to you
to give me some thoughts about that join
these discussions at davidpakman.com
reddit